Suicide Squad spoiler talk that's right
hopefully you've all seen Suicide Squad
by now if you haven't go ahead stick
around just know I'm gonna ruin the [ __ ]
out of the movie for you seriously
though this is for the worry I'm going
to talk about some spoilers in here that
I didn't talk about my spoiler free
review so I do have a spoiler free
review out there for you if you want to
see what I thought about the movie that
said let's talk some Suicide Squad
spoilers here which is Suicide Squad
another DC movie that's just completely
divisive I don't know if it's divisive
among critics and fans or fans and fans
and critics and critics point is some
people like it some people don't some
people love it some people hate it and
granted there are problems in this movie
I guess that you can say that about any
movie movies have problems and whether
or not those problems are enough to
compromise the entire movie going
experience for someone that's what
really divides moviegoers into two
groups liked it and didn't alright my
PSA is done let's talk about some
spoilers and [ __ ] one of the things I
liked about the movie like when I heard
enchantress is gonna be in this movie I
was like she's not stable is she gonna
be alright
is she gonna be on there Dame no not at
all she's actually the bad guy yeah and
Chantry sees her moment she screws over
a man to wall her she frees her big CGI
brother and now they're gonna build a
device to wipe out the world so they can
ruled it together I really liked it the
way she's like Jason she turns into The
Enchantress I loved the first time she
did that she says enchantress you see
that black hand come under her hand grab
her hand and then flip over now she's
The Enchantress one thing I didn't like
about The Enchantress it's the way like
they give her like wit I liked it when
she's all like Gollum and [ __ ] she's all
like gosh that was really cool and then
her brother helps her out and then she
looks all regal and you could you're
like oh that's what she looked like when
people on earth worshiped her as a
goddess however she's always moving like
this and [ __ ] and you can tell her head
is moving differently than her body so
she's like where's Johnny I just try you
oh I'm like why are you moving are you
just belly dancing for the [ __ ] of it
she's like a dee dee trust me I have a
didi I get it I can't sit still for [ __ ]
I just thought I was the only one what
can I say I'm just not used to my really
sexy enchantress is doing the same thing
I do yeah I do that all the time and her
brothers the hentai tentacle powers I
just didn't know what it was I'm fine
with the big CGI God slash demigod
baddie killing people I just don't know
what the tentacle is Suicide Squad vs.
tentacle porn what else would they fight
but the cameos in this one pretty cool
because I mean these people are from
differ
realms of the worlds that they're going
to be from different cities among the DC
Universe so Batman takes out Deadshot at
the beginning and then captain
boomerangs robbing a bank and you see
Ezra Miller as flash which actually
looked really cool you see Ezra Miller
as flash in that scene you're like all
right I want to see that the Joker and
Harley although they were a big thing in
the movie the Joker was not just one the
scene for Harley was a huge deal in the
movie she's a her and Deadshot it's
their movie but you can't have Harley
without having the Joker you just you
have to have the Joker in a movie that
introduces Harley Quinn otherwise people
can be like why is she nuts we didn't
get a lot of the Joker a lot of people
ask me like well how was it yeah how do
you like them how do you love them
because in like three scenes in the
entire movie I imagine they're gonna
have an extended cut that shows a lot
more or the Joker but it's just it's a
good introduction marketing-wise you
have this guy taking on the Joker that
is immediately following up Heath
Ledger's Joker granted they're different
jokers but you know everyone's going to
compare Jared Leto to Heath Ledger so at
that point you can have this new guy do
a joker in a movie that doesn't revolve
around the Joker get some feedback and
then the next director who might
actually be Ben Affleck for the Batman
standalone movie might be like okay
we're gonna fix this on this about the
Joker now there were things that like
things I didn't like I like the fact
that he is a mobster I like the fact
that he has businesses and [ __ ] round
out a bit of profit and Gotham that's
cool some of his lines were great some
of his lines were not when he's all like
oh god I'm like no couple times you
remind me to Jim Carrey reads like he's
so intense I was like that debts Jim
Carrey right there I watched in living
color I know that [ __ ] a couple of great
moments with the Joker those and Harley
goes into the acid bath then Joker turns
around you're like you just see that
he's gonna leave her absolutely alright
playtime's over she's dead and he stops
he's like and he rips off his jacket and
dives into the acid after hurt so you
dude started to care about her granted
he left her ass to die when they crashed
into the water and she couldn't swim my
favourite scene with the Joker those
when the chopper rolls around and his
guys on the Gatling gun just shredding
that roof and Joker just has a machine
gun he's just shooting laughing he's
like come on baby and he gets Harley I
was like that yes yes yes that right
there was a pretty sweet Joker moment
have more of those moments the next time
I'm saying anything I liked was El
Diablo I thought he'd added a lot to the
movies this dude who could clearly
incinerate a lot of [ __ ] and end a lot
of problems for a lot of people but he
just lays passive he's like I've wiped
out my family
I don't want to kill people I just like
it when you have the most powerful one
in the entire group who just chooses to
be a pacifist and then he's forced to
actually use his powers and he feels
like [ __ ] for it I like that scene Will
Smith's like I just wanted to get you
there we're good right you can tell he
says his look on his face like I told
you I didn't want to do that that's a
good part right there and I didn't touch
much on Amanda Waller in my spoiler free
review because I know that there are
people out there who don't really know
Amanda Waller is a [ __ ] bag so I don't
want to say hey by the way Amanda Waller
is a villain in the moment I mean
granted she's not the villain she's not
a god about to wipe out the world but
she is an [ __ ] so I want to save that
for people who might not know that Viola
Davis played Amanda Waller really well
and that is the scene in my spoiler free
review where I was like something
happens I just don't think that other
person would have dealt with it that way
it's when Amanda Waller like kills those
five people who are working for her
she's like let's go and Ric flags like
okay I ain't judging you could see it as
kind of bringing Ric flags true nature
out it's like oh well you're actually a
dick too I just don't see it that way
since for the entire film Rick flag has
been judging Deadshot for being a
murderer I got you're a murderer who
takes credit cards I'm gonna sit around
watch my boss kill those five people who
probably had families no big deal that
right there was even said well no I do
see a bit of a wasted opportunity with
Killer Croc where they had to go down
and get that bomb and detonate it under
the Enchantress's brother and kill him
Killer Croc goes down there and he just
gets like he's fighting these dudes over
here and then this Navy SEAL just
detonates it and blows himself up I
think it would have been really cool
since Killer Croc has been treated like
an animal then he became an animal they
established that earlier on in the movie
ultimately he's an [ __ ] because
people saw him as an [ __ ] just as
downward spiral he's in would have been
great is if he took the bomb it kind of
treated it like Doc Ock and spider-man 2
where he's like I will not die a monster
and he saves everybody it'd be great if
croc did that said something like that
push the button blew himself up it's
like oh [ __ ] Killer Croc was there's a
good dude I mean I know Killer Croc
supposed to be a good dude but since our
humanizing Deadshot why not in the end I
just I was impressed with how this movie
did handle a bunch of characters who
never got set up
we never got their backstory some people
may know their backstory but as the DC
Cinematic Universe goes we don't know
who these people are I thought flipping
the enchantress and making her the
[ __ ] is actually a smart move not CGI
wise done the best way they could have
done it but it was still a smart move
character wise it's a lot if I had a lot
of fun in this movie
this summer let's face it has been a
disappointing ask summer started off
great and then kind of its fizzled sense
so along comes Suicide Squad a movie
that just has fun with this absurd
premise and had fun with it had humor it
needed to have humor had badassery when
it needed to have badassery gave us the
feels with a couple of characters made
me interested in Jared Leto's Joker
where I ranked him ultimately as
underneath Heath Ledger Mark Hamill and
Jack Nicholson's Joker DS not above
those guys he is below that but I see
potential for him to expand it was
perfectly fine for the catalyst and the
tool of Harley Quinn's backstory which
is what he was in Suicide Squad alright
guys so Suicide Squad have you seen it
what did you think about it what do you
think of Jared Leto's Joker who's your
favorite character in the movie what do
you think of Harley Quinn what do you
think a Deadshot you want to see a
sequel do you want to see more whatever
you think of all of it comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more